[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us we know
that today we look at the power of self
confidence and how one man is trying to
instill it in young girls one dress at a
time Dana Jacobson shows us inspiring
project Dana good morning to you good
morning Gail online retail entrepreneur
Sam Sasaki doesn't have sisters or a
daughter even but he's made it his
mission to help girls across the country
believe in themselves his nonprofit
started when he donated a box of dresses
to those in need and that's when he
realized what can be achieved with the
help of one brand new piece of clothing
remember you from last time we were fast
this time we got you smaller ones for
just a few hours this is the Boys and
Girls Club in Washington DC's been
transformed into a personal shopping
experience
dozens of dresses for a select group of
girls to choose from all free of charge
online retailer Sam Sasaki is the
benefactor the dresses the fulfillment
of a promise he made to them in return
for a promise of their own I ask all the
girls what their dream is and I tell
them that in order to achieve a
long-term goal you need short term goals
and if they achieve it I actually mailed
them more dresses this sounds like it's
more than just a dress I want to give
them a belief system and something to
work towards and and support Society
says it's his own support system that
helped him launch his company us trendy
one of the leading online retailers for
young women three years ago his company
was taking off and he had too many
sample dresses so he decided to donate
them just went in there dropped off a
box of dresses and the appreciation lick
wasn't was incredible on the girls faces
how do you go from this idea of I want
to provide dresses and positive
reinforcement to actually being able to
sew so initially I did the samples and
that I ran out quickly so it was
initially like I'm going to retail
stores like in the womens department
people like what is this guy doing
buying dresses how much money did you
spend last year tens of thousands of
dollars was it worth it oh absolutely
that investment turned into dresses for
four thousand girls in cities across the
country Sam also decided that with every
dress there was one additional component
mentorship it is
so important for you to know who you are
and what you like they discuss body
image bullying and self-love I think
that you are a fantastic person
[Music]
Sam hopes together it will help them
achieve their dreams how many of you
guys know what you want to do when you
grow up what do you get from this when
you hear like what their goals are in
their dreams everything from the first
woman president to no surgeon to like
professional basketball player and it
reminds me of myself that childhood kind
of like dream that you have like so many
times along the way people let go of it
and so how do I foster that in nourish
it
the girls in Washington DC are now on to
their second and third goals my goal
doesn't stand tall when somebody brings
me down our goal is to finish 5th grade
children
Rihanna Robinson who wants to be
President one day is working on love and
a few other things make presidential
choices and to only be independent to
other people and to be strong she says
she'll think of Sam and his
encouragement when she wears her dress I
could remember a strong feeling that Sam
gave me like when he let me get this
dress feel silly but I don't feel silly
I feel happy empower it a little bit - I
feel fearless now and she was Sam is now
able to take donations so he's not
paying out of pocket as much he told us
that last year despite shelling out tens
of thousands of dollars as you heard it
was his favorite year in business he has
his own goals for this year reaching
10,000 girls and it really was the
messages not just the dress they love
the dress and they felt beautiful but
the messages of how to be a friend and
how to support others was really big
know the little girl said I want to be
president and a lawyer I like that a
good dress can make you feel good and
makes you feel strong and fearless she's
right no dying so much